shawn johnson calls nashville home and
only e.t was invited exclusively
inside her family dicks hey guys come on
in
[Music]
here let's see if he does tricks nash
come here are you set sit
hey oh you're a sweetheart
this is how we get sean to open the cap
let's see that you ready yeah one
two three oh my god
i love it it's continually humbling
every time i walk in here it's like all
right you got shawn's olympic
memorabilia and then you know i played
college are you kidding me
so it's your nfl jersey nfl
olympian i mean quite the athletic
household over here
no surprise andrew and shawn's 5 000
square foot pad
has its own gem there's also plenty of
space outdoors
a big master bath and check out the mini
kitchen for 11 month old daughter drew
hazel
well any signs of her being a little
athlete uh
yeah she's a bruiser i don't think
she'll be a gymnast because she takes
after her daddy
she'll be an athlete i'm sure
[Music]
hi beauty okay
oh my god just you people love y'all and
they really love
the east family youtube page as well we
kind of fell into it
and it's been a hot mess of a roller
coaster but i feel like i kept reading
articles about myself
and i was tired of being the gymnast and
i just wanted people to know me
we're gonna have a baby i remember when
we went through the miscarriage
it was the first time i ever saw social
media as not a one-sided platform
the only way i healed through the
miscarriage was actually talking to
women from around the world who
had gone through the same thing
how does it feel to be parents it's the
best
being a parent personally makes me feel
like i've like fulfilled a purpose that
i
never knew i had she's the greatest
little thing ever
the babies are hilarious i would never
go back now this is the best
you can yeah yeah i hate to break it to
you andrew but no turning back now buddy